est ce que ça vous choque eric zemmour
de voir rachida dans la rue comme ça
avec le voile oui et je vais vous je
vais lui dire pourquoi il est si vous
voulez est ce que vous imaginez
à la mecque une jeune femme en mini jupe
je ne suis pas là mais par respect pour
la mecque elle ne mettrait pas une
légion comment vous pouvez donc pour
vous mais je mets la france pour moi
être sacrés vous savez il ya un vieil
adage en france qui dit à rome fais
comme les romains donc à rome on fais
comme les romains à au maroc on fait
comme les marocains mais je suis
alors rachida merci d'être là rachida
vous êtes devenu une star aujourd'hui
tout le monde ne parle que de vous c'est
un truc de fou non mais je vous dis j'ai
eu jamais eu autant d'appels sur un
invité ça veut dire que tout le monde
m'a appelé parce qu'ils savaient que je
recevais rachida merci rachida en tout
cas d'être là merci de me recevoir vous
avez fait plus de télé que moi
aujourd'hui c'est assez rare
vouloir c'est vrai alors vous êtes
comptable vous êtes né au maroc
naturalisée française déjà on va parler
bien sûr de tout ce qui a été dit bien
sûr sur vous mais juste pourquoi avoir
accepté de rencontrer raymond va pouvoir
m'exprimer tout simplement ça lui ses
idées ses idées vous font peur non non
non parce que c'est vraiment des
extrêmes c'est des idées extrêmes donc
c'était vraiment pour avoir le
personnage en face ils vous en allez
vous avez vous l'avais trouvé
sympathique d'une impulsion aux échanges
oui mais c'est ça qui est grave oui
sympathique mais triste avait fallu
sortir de trois d'arcade
et donc oui groupe rémy vous étiez
content on ne le voit oui vraiment non
non franchement oui quand on m'a dit
voilà il y aura eric zemmour j'ai dit
pourquoi pas je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
personnes qui auraient à émettre à la
place way et je me suis dit fais il vous
a convaincu non pas du tout du tout mais
vous étiez dans les changes vous avez
vous aussi vous avez dialoguer avec lui
même si vous avez des idées complètement
différent il vous appartenait quand il
vous dit là quand on va s calame et
comporte une minijupe ou à rome j'ai pas
compris la comparaison ouais ça pour
vous sinon pourquoi on impose des choses
en arabie saoudite
donc ce qu'il veut c'est qu'en france
qu'on fasse la même chose là bas si
c'est des dictateurs la france on est
libre on élimine justement de porter ce
que l'on veut alors à beaucoup
reviennent sur eux vraiment cet extrait
qui a fait énormément parler quand vous
enlevez votre voile et nous vous allez
me dire si vous avez dit rachid a eu
raison c'est vrai qu'il ya eu pas mal de
polémiques sur vous concernant depuis
cet après midi à bout énormément de
polémiques qui ont surgi notamment à ont
dit que vous ne portiez pas le voile
porté le voile depuis quelques temps
puisque certains sont allés sur votre
compte facebook et ont vu que vous ne
portiez pas le voile alors il ne portait
plus neuf mois c'est ce qu'a dit jean
marc marino depuis le début de l'année
quoi à tout casser d'accord qu'est-ce
qui a fait que vous lui apportez chez
voila apres c 1 c'est une question de
foi mais je les dis
j'essaie de me retrouver dans ma foi et
je commence petit à petit mais pourquoi
proposer prix de l'addition comme ça
depuis quelques temps vous ai dit je
j'ai envie de porter le voile si la c
c'est le moment c'est un cheminement oui
pas fait donc c'est un cheminement vers
faire ma religion après je ne parle pas
au nom de tous les musulmans il faut
vraiment arrêter passer chacun fait ce
qu'il veut chacun fait vraiment ce qu'il
veut on en est on a vraiment le choix on
a le choix de le porter non parce qu'on
a le choix d'alain delon la polémique la
polémique origines je vous dis tout
c'est qu'il ya des loupiots ni oui ni
non mais en fait elle portait pas le
voile il ya encore une heure et le porte
maintenant à azemmour donc il faut dire
que vous ne portez plus nos veines je le
porte depuis neuf mois accor et j'espère
le porter encore le plus longtemps
possible
vous êtes vous êtes plus heureuse avec
le voile que sont loin je suis très
heureuse mais j'ai été très heureux
aussi au vent avant dakar avant je pense
que c'est vrai que donc il ya des gens
forcément je vous dis qu'il me dise en
sélection et qui ont concouru à la mise
en scène ce qu'ils se sont dit tiens
elle portait pas le voile avant on a été
voir sur ces son compte facebook elle
portait pas le voile est maintenant le
porte peut-être que c'est le pont de
facebook raconte toutes nos résidents
jusqu'à temps mais non mais je vous dis
voilà donc voilà le même style
résolument personnel j ai senti
exactement elle le port depuis neuf mois
donc voilà ya un débat là-dessus oui
gilles verdez oui c'est vrai que en
regardant vos réseaux sociaux et en
discutant avec des amis musulmans
notamment de drancy certains remettent
en cause vos convictions et ma question
elle est directe est ce que vous êtes
une comédienne un an du tout allanon
mais aussi comptable effectivement j'ai
travaillé pour un certain gros comédien
c'est de lambeaux ça coûte non mais
alors alors justement on va y revenir là
dessus parce que le la deuxième
polémique
voilà donc c'est aussi que vous avez
travaillé je vous dis que vous
travaillez pour pour le groupe bolloré
qui est l'actionnaire principal du
groupe canal+ et on rappelle que c'est
nous donc c'est une chaîne du groupe
canal
et on était vérifiée et vous ne
travaillez plus pour l'ogbl enchantera
club depuis maintenant combien de temps
depuis fin 2010 est exactement depuis
fin 2010 est depuis presque maintenant
cinq ans ouais on ne travaillait plus
pour le groupe bolloré vous travaillez
ou maintenant pour le groupe invivo
exactement pour le groupe il dit voilà
c'est bien ce qu'on a vérifié puisque on
est on a tout vérifié je vous cache pas
depuis la fin janvier 2018 exactement je
suis parti de chez bolloré et j'ai tout
de suite enchaîné d'accord très bien
donc voilà ne travaille plus dans le
groupe ensuite on certains ont dit aussi
que vous n'habitez pas drancy c'est vrai
vous habite à 40 kilomètres de nancy
mais en fait il ya plein de gens des
intervenants qui n'habitait pas drancy
en fait c'était pas le principe de
l'émission c'était à imiter nos
séquences de danse était eric zemmour
qui menacent in a fait et vous vous avez
été contacté donc par par des personnes
aux essais les équipes vous en dit quoi
est-ce que vous souhaitez participer à
face à face avec monsieur et mots
comment vous avez été contacté comment
ils vous ont trouvé par le biais de mon
frère d'accord dit parce que comme c'est
mon petit frère qui m'a dit voilà est-ce
que tu veux on m'a contacté est ce que
tu veux défendre le port du voile pour
toi d'accord elle est pour toi face à
eric zemmour d'accord mais il faudra se
déplacer chez n'y a pas de souci
d'accord alors c'est justement petit
frère et je pars avant beaucoup bravo
petit frère comme il a eu l'info par des
amis à lui après c'est le bouche à
oreille il ya des personnes qui
travaillent chez la production qui
connaissent des amis de mon frère et
puis voilà ils ont demandé s'il
connaissait pas quelqu'un dans son
entourage on peut avoir participé à
cette émission alors eric zemmour n'a
pas été préparé un moment on vend une
émission en direct jérémy pas il a
devancé ça en direct et là on apprend
que les gens je vous dirais mais les
gens et les gens ont été créés en tchat
rachida est rachida elle était prévue
dans l'émission et d'autres intervenants
déjà depuis vendredi pour dire que
android on savait qu'ils allaient
intervenir dans l'émission créée nous
oui mais tu as fait truc
alors c'est toujours comme ça personne
de la sécurité tuque à ce que les gens
meurent c'est mort
les gens
avaient des jean castex messi targa sur
camer dur interpellé directement eric
zemmour on a bien vu qu'elle était
passée personne et il a répondu d'un air
c'est ma vraie rachida n'est pas là
c'est pas mais je suis j'ai joui ça
servirait de cette époque là non pas par
contre 6 1% à 9 heures du matin par la
suite mais j'ai pas mais moi j'ai pas
aimé cette émission je vous le dis j'ai
pas aimé ce qui s'est passé j'ai pas
aimé les 50 sinon cas et on vient et on
fait d'une veut on fait deux moines vous
êtes moi aussi je peux faire que zemmour
voilà celui qui dès qu'un délinquant
j'enlève les allocations désaccord à lui
qui sera resté de finir je relève son
salaire tenir ce luthier pas règles
réglo avec la france je le laisse à
celui qui porte le voile juan lève c'est
pas comme ça la france ça se passe pas
comme ça votre amour il arrive là et
même je vous dis je vous dis je te même
ses nuances qu'il fait ça même si new
skies fait avec moi on dit une chose
c'est bien il a faim grand coup c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit il a réussi son
coup mais pour moi tout ça c'est pipo et
compagnie c'est pas parce que tu as
grandi à drancy il est parti de drancy
pendant des années on refait le symbole
on retourne à drancy tout ce qu'il
disait mot évidemment moi je vais vous
le dire je le dis franchement nos
délinquants qui fout le bordel en france
on lui enlève ses allocs c'est facile à
dire moi je peux le dire aussi si vous
voulez ça dit bien ce petit jouet mais
ça fait plaisir aux gens cécile fait que
du plaisir aux gens quand il vous a dit
voulu pour la fin de vous lui enlevez
votre travail il dit alors c'est ça on
va voir l'extrait comment ils insistent
en venant l'ex messin
il n'avait pas vous cherchez la liberté
risque madame que je suis n'est pas la
couleur que je porte je sais alors
enlevé le ciseau foulard n'a pas
d'importance mais on est votre cravate
mais je l'enlève tremblé mais moi aussi
je mets la cravate n'est pas
dire
allez-y madame couleurs si la poisse non
mais bon c'est la jonction élèves n'en
revenais pas la fois ce que vous enlevez
votre toujours que vous enlevez
vous aimez juge décide allez vous
décidez l'envié vous décédez mambé voilà
très bien
non vous l'enlevez pas le voilà à la
trêve à la voile a très bien vous voyez
là là vous respecter la laïcité c'est
madame respecte
alors juste vous n'aviez jamais
rencontré eric zemmour de votre vie non
jamais alors eric zemmour m'a appelé
extrait tout à l'heure pour me dire je
n'ai jamais rencontré cette dame de ma
vie juste vous me confirmez ah ouais là
je connais pas ce monsieur seulement à
la télé qu'il n'avait jamais rencontré
cette femme de sa vie après je vous le
dis chacun fait comme il veut dans ses
missions c'est vrai que voilà et c'était
normal qu'ils prévoient de trois
intervenants sur je vois pas
sur des gens non mais c'est obligatoire
et ce qu'on voit mais tu peux te
retrouver comme un conte où seules ses
odeurs du matin sont en effet inquiets
suprême entérine mais tu l'as vu toi
quand vous verrez ce que j'aimais tout
si tu te dis que personne personne peut
être avec des vrais générant tir qui
vont dire les membres est vraiment bon
j'adore ce que tu dis j'aime bien ton
temps d'abord grâce aux lancers mais là
c'est le producteur qui permet la
production d'une émission mitigée
papiers oubliés pintus a prévu
mécaniciens prévus que j'étais déjà
dans son truc surtout ce qu'il a dit
avant je peux comprendre et été
franchement je respecte ce que dit
raymond et je peux le comprendre et je
suis peut-être parfois voilà peut-être
d'accord avec lui mais sur des choses
mais là sur ça tu dis excuse moi raymond
n'importe quoi parce que c'est une
télévision c'est de la télé tu peux
arriver là-bas et te dire il ya personne
qui veut parler tu te réveilles qu'une
caméra les jo j'ai pas envie de parler
d'acte en direct du 30 10 ans du matin
c'est le diamant pas bon s'il vous plaît
la chérèque répond
[Rires]
je suis
honnêtement effectué moi je te rejoins
je trouve que le très beau coup serment
dès qu'il a fait pour le coup il ya les
trois noms il ya non parce que moi je
suis effectivement ça où pour une fois
où il était en face d'un public et moi
franchement je veux qu'on découvre bien
le bon et mots et ça me semblait bien
c'est une chose que plus on va faire
comme ça et plus les gens vous réseau
quant à madame tussauds qu'est ce
qu'elle a fait est formidable parce
qu'effectivement elle a dit je le retire
que c'est mon choix et j'ai beaucoup
aimé et en plus d'autres cas les
bienfaits de rupture est bien sûr
d'aller et en plus si cette séquence
très mal et du bien de voir cette
séquence il a fait une grosse erreur
quand c'est tellement il est dit que des
bêtises parce qu'effectivement le voilà
et là on va dire des bêtises et dès que
dès que la phase i des u 17 ligue
nationale et parce qu'on franc estimant
raymond on peut porter le voit il dit
mais sur ce point là il dit au journal
dans celui qui est délinquant il ne
mâche pas rêver linea oui j'ai bien dit
que des chiffres sur des gens qui disent
que c'est au père est mon des gens qui
se contentent de la laïcité se financent
qu'on peut on peut y lire prédictive ont
chacun a le droit d'avoir la région qui
le souhaitent il je suis d'accord c'est
ça la laïcité est réel pour cette
raison-là cette séquence cas est très
important c'est qu'il est d'une grosse
bêtise et depuis 2004 une loi qui est
sorti on peut porter le voile dans les
rues de paris ou de léo de france
exactement c'est de nommer stérile et à
rennes le dire et arrête de dire que
c'est de la wii u 19 les lives et dvd
ces deux-là permettre c'est que moi la
séquence à permettez vous êtes arrêté
vous je trouve que c'est d'un ridicule
mais c'est c'est pas entendable en fait
moi ce qu'on vient de voir je suis
révolté parce qu'à un moment donné on se
fout de la gueule des gens qui regardent
les émissions nous on croit qu'il ya des
choses compte année on pense que ça se
passe comme ça comme ça et là on est en
train d'apprendre que la dame elle n est
pas contre vous dit tout c'est la preuve
que la production je vous avez rejoint
c'est quoi ça les mêmes chances qu'il
fasse les gens chez nous c'est les mêmes
gens qui viennent des gens chez nous
mais il faut en fait que ce soit les
mêmes gens qui pour nous annoncer que là
je peux donner mon avis en tant que
téléspectatrice ça ne me plaît pas de
voir sa pas se dire que là chaque
personne a été choisie on connaissait
cette dame on sait pas du
mépris non mais c'est parce que tout -
chrysler qui doit crier ça me saoule
kelly kelly kelly quand je fais btp les
gens qui viennent sur le plateau je les
cas ce qu'avance est normal mais si un
gibier aux jantes ont illuminé ma
musique et mes envies mais la mémoire
mais il est temps la rue eric zemmour et
non la femme appelle des gens vous
faites semblant sur le comprends c'est
terrible quand tu invites des gens
jettent j'invite pour un des bars et des
dirigeants les deux spécialistes la télé
vous comprenez rien carrément aller chez
les messieurs je vous adore je sais mais
bien parce qu'on est les deux secondes
les spéciales sont pas pro des médias
mais eh ben non on pense comme le femise
non ils ont annoncé dans les spectacles
à l'horizon non non non mais je vais
leur expliquer je vais leur expliquer
s'il vous plaît parce que en fait oui 13
non parce que là c'est un faux débat
salle et chérie là on est sûr à china
sur le fond et voilà on entre sida qui
fallait une raison de faire ce qu'elle
voulait un moment que c'est ce calvaire
fait mes armes et rachida jours
approchent c'est l'hypocrisie de
l'émission
les toits du coup mais kelly kelly
raymond joseph au sketch voilà ça c'est
pas faux sketches elle savait pas
qu'elle ait les savait pas que
l'héritier aulas lui demander ça et oui
ça n'est pas les changes qu'elle allait
avoir ce que je joue et je vous explique
quand vous allez dans une école fait une
émission bien entendu même quand c'est
dans la rue vous préparer des choses
apparemment excédé partir comme un ouf
parce que je suis un abruti mais juste
les mecs jean marc morandini quand il
fait des missions il va adro si vous
croyez vraiment qu'il va y aller comme
ça la fleur au fusil il va y avoir il
sait qu'il va y avoir de l'imprévu donc
forcément il ya des gens qui auraient
pas gai zemmour et le savez il ya une
dizaine de personnes qui ont gagné mais
ils avaient prévu d'aider à londres avec
des gens qui ont été déjà prévu à
l'avancé mais il savait pas qu'elle
était là ne teneur des échanges qu'elle
n'a jamais rencontré guy moore abandon
qu'ils savaient pas ce qu'ils allaient
se dire mais tu es obligé de bach et
parce que imaginons je pense que il
adorerait aller là bas et bien on va
aller là-bas depuis on n'a personne de
castetpugon facteurs un truc comme ça
mais le problème c'est que tu peux te
retrouver je te le dis y'a pas de drancy
à 10 heures du matin et tu peux te
retrouver comme un conte où il ya que
des mecs qui te disent moi je ne veux
pas parler avec ses moyens mais moi je
comprendrai tout à fait qu'il ait des
gens qui disent moi j'ai pas envie de
parler avec des mots parce que ses idées
elle ne me conviennent pas et que tu
peux tu t'imagines frère tu veux le
mettre en face d'une barbe d'une dame
qui porte le voile comment tu fais ça
virtual a grossi imagine la probabilité
dallas grossi de trouver une femme qui
porte le voile qui veut bien parler avec
zemmour c'est impossible parce que en
fait tu prépares le truc quand tu vas
aller dans une boucherie halal on va
voir l'excellent tout à l'heure ici dans
quel boucherie valais c'est normal mais
je vais vous dire ça c'est juste de la
production mais le débat n'est pas là
c'est juste qu'aujourd'hui le
probabilité d'avoir les changes entre
rachida eric zemmour au hasard comme ça
et on est en partant comme ça la fleur
au fusil à lancy et ses proches de zéro
c'est à dire sont vraiment avoir une
chance inouïe donc forcément même
mathieu qui qui qui voit là que tu es
d'accord là dessus je reconnais qu'il
est c'est vous dire les chéris non ça
moi ce que j'ai roulé cette fois on est
quand même sur cette histoire voile et
est-ce qu'elle a bien fait d'enlever loi
parce que j'ai vu des gens sur les
réseaux sociaux aussi qui est je sais
qu'aujourd'hui c'est on est un petit peu
compliqué pour nous parce qu'il ya plein
de gens qui ont dit elle aurait jamais
dû l'enlever c'est inadmissible qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ces à ces gens à
ce que je voulais montrer aujourd'hui
c'est que je suis une femme et surtout
je suis libre c'est que le voile j'ai
décidé de le porter on me l'a pas
imposée c j'ai choisi du jour au
lendemain peut-être de porter ce tissu
ce qu'on m'a dit pourquoi la plainte
issue c'est paris j'aime c'est juste un
foulard un bout de tissu j'ai décidé de
porter pour un bar et face à monsieur
zemmour ce que je voulais eut démontré
c'est que ni lui ni mon père ni mon
frère ni à aucun homme n'a le droit de
décider à ma place je me pose une
question madame mais tout bien sûr
monsieur non alors alors et et madame
est ce que ça veut dire que si par
hasard eric zemmour passait et que et la
loi justement fait qu'il interdisait le
port du voile est ce que du coup vouloir
de février où est ce que vous seriez le
pays qu'est ce que vous feriez je cause
les bras en v mais en imaginant c'est
une que soit domaine il a raison voyez
jamais qu'est ce que vous feriez je le
portais pas avant quelques mois ça ne
m'a pas empêché de travailler d'accord
donc là si on devait nous l'imposé 6 à 2
il ya un texte de loi qui devait voilà
tiens vous êtes une femme vous devez pas
porter le voile j'appliquerai la loi
comme tout le monde d'accord